what is sci-fi and what does it mean to
the two of you huh
wow that's an interesting question
that's a big question well I take it
links I'm the science fiction geek well
it was science fiction it's a wonderful
playground because it allows it allows
us to comment on our world but in a way
that makes it much more Universal now
for instance when Rod Serling came up
with Twilight Zone
he was censored by the network's and
sponsors in terms of saying anything he
wanted to say about politics or race or
social issues of the day so he created
Twilight Zone so we could comment on
those things without the censors
removing it and as a result those
Twilight Zone episodes are as timely now
in the Trump era as they ever were when
he was writing in an Eisenhower was
president or Kennedy was president so I
love the fact that science fiction
allows me to reach an audience of
millions of people around the world and
the work lasts decades and actually
centuries ultimately and it also seems
to inspire people because there were so
many things that were jumped off from
things like Star Trek where geek you
know eat kids grew up to be geek
scientists and they actually jumped in
and they they made it real so it really
is inspirational and one thing that I
really like about science fiction is
it's the same thing with stories in
small towns or westerns it's where a lot
of the complexity of modern life is
stripped away and we can really focus on
moral and emotional issues in a much
clearer way yes yeah and also if you
kill a character you can bring them back
because you can clone them or whatever
it's really funny do you remember the
first time the two of you were exposed
to the first sort of sci-fi story and
where you were how old you were yeah
well yeah well between the two of us I'm
the real science fiction geek I mean
Elaine was reading Dostoevsky when she
was a kid and I told her I wanted a
robot I want a robot yeah exactly but
the my first experience with science
fiction I you know when I was a kid I
was reading comic books from as early as
I can remember my first favorite book
was farmer in the sky by Robert Heinlein
when I
seven I just grew up in the genre
Twilight Zone Star Trek Outer Limits
those are the three shows that made me
want to be a writer and as soon as I was
a teenager I started going to science
fiction conventions and meeting those
writers the writers had written for
those shows Harlan Ellison DC Fontana
David Gerald Theodore sturgeon Richard
Matheson George Clayton Johnson Ray
Bradbury and they many of them became
friends and mentors and so I definitely
knew where home was for me and I was
more brought up on the social older the
social issues than some of the older
writers like 1984 and and HG Wells were
they were really exploring social issues
so that was when you were right as I
knew the older ones and my parents
leaned strongly to the left and so did I
and so we found their ability to explore
things where people would not put up
walls because in the future allow them a
much greater freedom to reach into
people's thought processes and feelings
without defensiveness sort of some of it
you know the I mean I just was you know
when I was a kid I was given a Christmas
present of a trip to the Star Trek set
so I was there for the last episode of
the original Star Trek ever shot
turnabout intruder so I got to sit in
the captain's chair and stand on the
transfer I remember looking up and
seeing there was just a light bulb screw
it to transporter above above my head
and I had huh whoa gee and I remember
thinking how small the engineering on
the Star Trek's that was a force
perspective and I was thinking gee this
is a lot smaller than it looks on
television and it was just an amazing
day really a really wonderful wonderful
day of great the best Christmas present
ever
Elaine do you remember the first time
you heard about Space Command oh my god
well no I I don't seem to be a Buddhist
they tell you what you wanted into it's
you've been talking about it like
forever you know but but I I actually
don't remember what when did you first
set me up with well you know it's funny
because with Space Command it evolved
over a period of time it was basically
you know as I said start Star Trek was
really the formative moment in my life
once when Star Trek
debut the first episode was the mantrap
it aired when I think Star Trek debuted
when I was 10 years old and and it was
the thing I've been waiting all my life
for it really brought everything
together and and I think from from the
moment that I read the making of Star
Trek when I was 13 I decided I wanted to
be a showrunner I wanted to create and
run my own science-fiction show and all
the hundreds of hours of television I
did all the books I wrote were all
toward learning that gaining those
skills that I would need to be able to
do that thing and when Miley and Ike got
together I mean we've been together for
40 years we've been married for 39 she
was a terrific director she'd already
been a director off-broadway she already
been an actress she was a wonderful
writer and so on some projects we would
collaborate on other projects we would
work individually over the years but
clearly with Space Command it was
obvious that I would meet her skill set
and and we both loved working with
actors we love working with editors and
I love visual effects artists I love
concept designers and so forth so I've
been gathering a team and so from the
beginning I knew I wanted to work with
Elaine on this project the key
jumping-off point was we were feeling
both feeling very disturbed about the
dark and cynical turn that science
fiction had taken yeah and he introduced
me well I guess I knew a little bit
before but he was a great fan of things
like Space Patrol and it was where you
know bad things happen but good people
were good people
what will speak just to jump in for a
second Space Patrol was a
science-fiction show that aired live in
the 1950s and I didn't grow up watching
it but in the 1980s us a cable I had a
show called night flight and they ran
kinescopes of that show that kinescopes
were filmed basically you'd put a camera
a 16 millimeter camera on a height like
a high resolution TV screen as the show
was broadcast live and you'd record it
on film and those were called kinescopes
and so they were airing those kinescopes
of space command and it was a wonderful
show it became before Star Trek but it
had a great sense of adventure and later
I met the star of the show ed camera
who'd actually been a pilot in world war
ii he he flew up p-51 Mustang had been
shot down he was captured by the Germans
escaped from a German POWs camp he was a
real hero before he played a science
fiction hero in the night
and he looked like when he seemed like
very handsome man and so so that was
part of the inspiration and then of
course Star Trek and and when Elaine was
talking about the dark science fiction
there's a period a few years ago where
all the science fiction was very dark
and very to stop ik whether it was
Battlestar Galactica which I very much
liked or Elysium or after earth or any
of these things they all were saying the
future is gonna be really bad and
there's not anything you can do about it
and and people and most people are
mean-spirited and things don't work out
well right and what was odd or what my
pointed out what was odd was that this
is being written by writers his life
it's pretty darn good hundreds of
thousands of dollars or millions of
dollars so somehow there was a
disconnect between the life they were
creating personally and the work they
were writing and and I felt very
strongly that science fiction outer
limits Twilight Zone Star Trek those
shows had a moral compass and Bay and
particularly Star Trek said the future
is going to have challenges
Star Trek was shot during the civil
rights movement during the Vietnam War
and yet it said the future is going to
have challenges but we can reach across
boundaries and barriers and come
together to create something better and
I thought that was very important too to
say now and some of it it's not just
about science efficiency objective of
storytelling I mean if we assume that
most people have kind of a hard life I
mean somebody in their family is
mentally ill somebody is on substances
and they're struggling you work hard and
you go and you watch a story and it says
well things are really dark and awful
and you don't have any hope and it's all
going to go to hell
and you say well is that really
responsible stand to take or do you want
your audience to go out of there and
saying okay it's a struggle but people
can come out on top people are basically
good at heart if you just give them a
shot and you give people a sense when
they leave that theater that there's
possibility it just seems far more
accurate and socially responsible and
you put them on a downer well you know
it's we work in an extremely powerful
medium you know television reaches
millions of people around the world if
you do it right at last forever most of
the shows I've written for is still
being watched even the ones that I wrote
when I was in my early 20s and and so
there's there's a question that many
writers never ask themselves which is as
far as I can tell which is am I actually
creating something that's making the
world a better place
am I actually sending out a message
that I would want people to take to
heart you know TV can do one of three
things it can either anesthetize or fill
people with despair or inspire people
and I think the first obligation of any
drama dramatic entertainment is to
entertain obviously if you don't
entertain you know it doesn't matter
what your message is people want to
stick around for it but beyond that once
you entertain people once you bring them
into your world and they love that world
and want to be part of that world then
if you can say well you know take these
lessons take what you've seen in the
story take it out into the real world
take it out into your life you can
actually have a better life you can make
a better world I think those are very
important messages to communicate not a
airy-fairy you know like not sugarcoat
anything because people don't like to be
lied to and they know when they're being
lied to like oh everybody's happy
everybody's you know but but but if you
within a real context where you say okay
things are hard you get into a bad mood
you say the wrong thing but you can be
be man enough to apologize you know that
those are the kinds of things you like
to address yeah yeah mark when you were
first creating Space Command was it in
your mind that you were going to attempt
to sell it to a studio it's very
interesting you know when I started in
television I've been I've been a
professional writer since I was 19 I
sold actually in truth my first radio
play aired when I was 18 on KPFK my
first short story I sold when I was 19 I
started writing my first book when I was
22 the twilight zone companion and I was
writing for television by the time I was
22 or 23 and when I started in
television if you wanted your work to
reach millions of people it had to be
through a studio and a network and there
were only three networks ABC NBC and CBS
and also PBS you know public television
and that was it
and so now and also you had to shoot on
35 millimeter or 16 and you edited on a
movie olla and it was it cost millions
of dollars to make any television
program per episode now of course it's
very very different you can shoot on a
digital camera we own a red and you you
add it on a laptop our editor is back at
our place right now editing Space
Command on our laptop and it's hooked up
to our big-screen TV and and and you can
reach out to your audience your audience
can help
is what you're doing and you can also
reach and reach millions of people via
the internet so you know a lot of people
stay stuck in the way things used to be
and I think that's a big mistake I
embraced the new model and I love the
new model and I love the direct
communication with my audience I feel
that I'm the same as my audience and so
if I like something if I'm enthusiastic
about something I know my audience will
be too and and so with Space Command
initially my idea was I it's funny when
I first came up with the idea of doing a
hopeful vision of the future it's this
multi-generational saga that covers 150
years in the future it takes place in
the solar system and beyond and a lot of
my friends run Network shows and a
number of them said to me well you know
listen we can team up and we can walk
this into a network and get a pilot deal
but but I knew from experience that if I
sold it in a probably would sell I'd be
hired to write the script and then the
network could cut it off it's script and
then they would own it no one would ever
see it or they could greenlight the
production of the pilot and then we'd
shoot the pilot and if they didn't
greenlight it to series again no one
would ever see it or if they you know
greenlit series they might have notes
that would screw it up and ruin it so so
I thought well no let me see if I can
raise money I've never raised money
before but I said let's let's see if I
can reach out to the audience I mentor
thousands of young people in Hollywood
well actually people of all ages view of
the roundtable I run in the classes I
teach and I've been hearing about
crowdfunding and so I thought well let's
see if I could do that so um our target
was seventy-five thousand dollars to
raise in two months we hit that in three
days and we kept going and we raised two
hundred twenty-one thousand dollars and
that ice-cold investment shares to my
backers and raised another half million
and we're still going strong and so that
was enough to open our own studio shoot
the first two hours of space command
shoot 30 minutes of the second two hours
I've written the first eight hours and
outlined hours nine through twelve so
that's a season so then the question is
well do I want to take it to a network
do is there a reason to take it to a
network if you've gotten this much of a
head of steam there are over 500
scripted comedies and dramas on all the
various networks and platforms now 500
series the cost of rolling out a show
promoting it just so people know it
exists is 23 million dollars I can raise
enough money to make space come in it I
can't
enough money to promote space command so
that's where a studio and a network or
more ideally more specifically a network
or big platform like Netflix or Amazon
makes sense because if I really want to
reach a world audience on a broad scale
if I want this to really last and and
reach the people I want to reach that
makes a lot of sense and the fact of the
matter is that he started out wondering
it would be a single film and what
happened was once we started with the
crowdfunding something that we hadn't
seen as an aspect of crowdfunding wasn't
just gathering money to shoot something
but it was gathering awareness worldwide
yeah and that awareness through us
because we're both soft bunny people we
said maybe a few other people are really
down on this dark trend and we'll want
to see something that's hopeful hopeful
vision of the future and in fact the
outpouring was so great that's what
ignited this crazy ambition in this mad
well yes and and it started to grow and
grow and grow he said well maybe two
maybe three and so although it started
as a single it became a much larger
story right and became you know how
about ongoingly
and we've had investors just walk up to
him and say I invested in this because I
want to do some see something that gave
me hope
yes specifically you know and so we
realized that something that was
troubling to us was profoundly troubling
to vast numbers all across well you know
it's funny because during our Space
Command campaign I got a phone call and
it turns out that there's a real Space
Command it's the space going arm of the
United States Air Force and they called
me a major in the Air Force called me I
thought oh gosh they're either gonna
want to shut me down or have me changed
the name and I got on the phone with
with with with major Glenn Roberts of
the US Air Force he says we love what
you're doing we want to be part of it
great so but the funny part is doing our
campaign if you typed Space Command into
Google we came in first and the Air
Force came in second and even to this
day if you type in Space Command the Air
Force comes in first and we come in
second even still so millions of people
around the world know about space
command thousands gave us money and
which is very very heartening but yes as
Elaine was saying originally it was
going to be one to our story and I
actually wrote half of it before the
campaign and then immediately sat down
afterwards and wrote this
and half of that to our script but
because I was doing media interviews
every single day of the campaign as I
talked about Space Command the story
started to grow in my mind and a zillion
said it grew to from two hours to four
hours to six hours to eight hours and
finally it was a whole series and so I
when I sat down and wrote the first so
what had was originally going to be the
first two hours ultimately became the
fourth story the fourth two hours story
and so I sat down one of the other
scripts so the the first ones the first
so I've written for four of the two
hours scripts already and and what was
going to be the first one is now going
to be the fourth one so if you ever go
back to our original Kickstarter
campaign the actors I'm talking about as
being in Space Command actually now are
in that fourth one so it's Armin
shimerman from deep space 9 and Buffy
Christina Moses who just started
containment Ethan Phillips from Star
Trek Voyager etc so sort of like a loose
torrent and he sleeps more and more
because yes well the loving thing is
that all the actors I approached many of
them stars from shows I'd worked on said
yes and so I mean my friend Mark Mike
Carney from orange is the new black and
Doug Jones who starred in Pan's
Labyrinth and Hellboy and the strain
he's gonna be starring in the new Star
Trek TV show Star Trek discovery and
Mira furlan from Babylon 5 and lost and
bill Mumy from Babylon 5 and lost in
space and Bob Carter from Star Trek
Voyager and Stargate Stargate Atlantis
these are wonderful actors James Hong
who was in Blade Runner and Big Trouble
in Little China he's one of my heroes
he's phenomenal to work with Anne
Ferrante here who was in JJ Abrams Star
Trek movie and iron man and you know
Elysium I mean these are phenomenal
actors and and I'm honored to be working
with him it's just it's just such a joy
I wanted to go back to something you
said about being adverse to learning
something new and just giving something
a try I think you'd written I was just
doing research last night I was maybe on
the super mentors or mark secrete calm
but it was about learn something new I
think that was the title of the post
maybe I'm paraphrasing but um especially
for people maybe Generation X or older
they don't want to learn something new
but Millennials I think you're much more
open to it because they've been exposed
to you know all of this technology what
do you say to that to someone that is
very set in their ways about working in
a certain medium and and
it holds them back in some ways well
here's the question about the first
question always says what do you want to
accomplish and the second question is am
i succeeding at that if you're not
succeeding then you have to change what
you're doing if you're committed to
reaching the finish line most people
stay stuck in the real question is what
is the operational phrase of your life
for many people the operational phrase
of their life is I'm not getting what I
want well if that's the if that's the
sentence that's ruling your life you've
got to find another sentence and so it's
much more liberating if the sentence is
I'm gonna get to the finish line and I'm
going to learn what I need to learn I'm
going to find what I need to find I'm
going to team up with whom I need to
team up with I'm going to create what I
need to create so that's liberating and
so from but but also you have to say let
me try something if it doesn't work I'll
try something else a lot of people are
very afraid of failing and you know it's
very funny because you know Lena Lane
will often talk about well you know if
you fell down in real life would you
just stay down no you get up you
continue on you know and so so but a lot
of people feel that if they fail that's
the end of it the doom will ensue and
that's not what happens and so and then
it's another thing that I've always
found very funny is when people say well
life is like a river and you it'll take
you where you're meant to go and I
always say to them if you fell into a
real river would you have that opinion
and it's like no you'd swim like hell to
get to the shore life is not like a
river life is basically deciding what
you want to accomplish life is not your
you it's very rarely very rarely that
you're handed something on a plate what
it's like here this will be easy
almost everything we try to do is hard
it's difficult but the more we're
willing to say well I'm getting I'm
going to get where I'm going you know
that's that's what happens but it's more
than what you want to accomplish I think
that there's a very poisonous thing that
we get taught from the time that we were
very small which is that it's enough to
not be happy you know we don't think
that if you're not happy that it's
enough so happiness is something that we
deserve that we all deserve
to say that well I'm leaving in okay
life I don't think that's okay he
doesn't think that's okay it's like no
if you're not feeling happy if you're
not feeling like you're doing your best
I really believe that all of us were
born with gifts that belong to the world
and if we're too afraid to deliver them
well that's just a loss that's just sad
and I think a lot of it is linked to
actually enthusiasm and feeling happy
and giving that original piece that
we're all born with yeah well a few
years ago I had to figure out the secret
of life I was going to be talking to an
audience of at a high school there's
going to be parents and teenagers
they're teenage kids and they're younger
kids and I said what do I want to talk
about and I thought I just don't want to
tell you no war stories from working in
Hollywood so I thought well maybe I
maybe be useful I told them the secret
of life so I had to figure out what that
was and it had to be simple so that even
little kids could understand it so what
I said was I said as near as I can
figure the secret of life is be happy be
kind be brave that's it and sometimes
you can't be all three at once but it's
important to strive for those three
things and I think that will that will
lead to a meaningful life and and a life
worth living and and also the other
thing is that you know it's very easy to
have an initial enthusiasm for a
creative project but it's very hard when
things start to become difficult when
you have to be there for the long haul
and it's also particularly difficulties
you don't know if you're gonna succeed
so often you're in the darkness and
that's where you need to surround
yourself with other people who have
faith when you falter years ago when I
graduated from UCLA as an art major by
the time I got out of UCLA I knew I
wanted to be a writer rather than visual
artist even though I'd had art you know
gallery shows of my work my paintings
and my photography of one when I was a
teenager I knew I wanted to be a writer
I wanted to be a writer producer in TV
and there were no classes and how to do
that so I decided I would write a book
about the Twilight Zone TV show to learn
how to do that job so I started writing
The Twilight Zone companion and we
started submitting it as a project
publishers and for a two-year period it
was rejected it was rejected by 25
publishers and had it just been me I
would have given up but Elaine said keep
going keep going and we figured out what
why it wasn't selling
we fired the agent we had who had been
Rod Serling's literary agent and we got
another agent she submitted it back to
one of the publishers who rejected it to
a different editor and the book sold and
the book was an instant bestseller when
it came out it sold over half a million
copies is still imprinted all these
years later but if I hadn't had a lain
in my life who believed in me even when
I faltered the book I wouldn't have
finished the book someone else would
have come out with a book on The
Twilight Zone and I would have just
spent the life the rest of my life and
bars being bitter yes so so again we
should have been odd because he doesn't
drink really I would have just believed
those peanuts and drinking like diet
soda or something it would have been
really wasted life but again it's very
important to surround yourself with
people who love you and people who
believe in you
and it's a two-way street so a lane will
falter and and have that you know dark
days and I'll say no no let's let's keep
on this path so it's a two-way street
and that's really important and I'm
wondering about fear of success because
I know that that also is something that
people think they don't have but it's a
huge thing because everything around you
would then change people treat you
differently maybe people would be
fearful of you or envious of you yes
it's terrible to have a lot of money
part of it is a mythos of a golden door
Here I am you know I have bad thoughts
are you with my mom you know I'm not a
good enough person but if I go through
the golden door everything will be
changed and wonderful and I'll wake up
with my hair in order and it's all going
to be great and it's this fear of this
great transition of something that you
can't come up to where people be waiting
for you to fall and there are people who
from envy wait beautiful but if you
don't see life as this you know is you
know that you can always fall fall on
your face but just that you are who you
are and you're just struggling on a slow
you know uphill throw will always be
downs but that you can come always fight
your way back up I think some of that
that fear is that you they the publicity
machines create an unrealistic vision of
who you are when you're when you write
well like you're suddenly a celebrity
and you're this different person and no
you you're the same schlubby person but
you're right well you know it
well I'm gonna bounce a little bit
because there's several things about
this part of fear of success I think
fear of scrutiny because the moment
you're on the world stage and the
spotlights on you you're very worried
that again as I am saying you could
falter you could fail etc but the good
part of it is that first of all you get
paid very well that's very nice and but
you have to make sure that the money
doesn't rule you so in other words you
it's a good idea to keep your overhead
low so that you don't have to take every
job that's offered to you we've turned
down more work than we've taken because
we that allows us first of all to learn
new skills it also allows us to follow
our own creative bent whether or not
it's immediately lucrative so we're not
ruled by money we keep our overhead low
but also there's two hollywood's
there's a Hollywood of awful
materialistic neurotic crazy people who
are a destructive and toxic and dreadful
and they get a lot of the press and
there's another Hollywood equally real
that's that's composed of people who are
wonderfully talented creating amazing
work they come from the heart they love
their families they go home they're not
crazy and they're doing it for the right
reason
each Hollywood is equally real and those
kind of people are all up and down the
food chain so what you've to decide is
first which Hollywood you want to belong
to and secondly which Hollywood you want
to exemplify
you want to be and and so what I do what
I've done in my whole career
is I gravitate toward the good Hollywood
so when I started writing The Twilight
Zone companion I was crawling crawling
from Rod Serling's attic I was literally
and I was interviewing all the people
who worked with him and I was seeing
what great people they were creating
great wonderful work that changed the
world that made people better in you
know then I wrote the book with
Guillermo del Toro and and one of my
mentors was Ray Bradbury so I was
deliberately choosing people who first
of all I could learn from but secondly
who should reinforce my belief that you
could be a good person you could speak
from authenticity you could be kind and
compassionate and that would not destroy
your career in fact it would make your
career better you had a greater chance
of succeeding by being authentic by
being genuine by being loyal and
honorable than if you were some kind of
Hollywood snake
I think some people believe they have to
turn themselves into monsters to succeed
the exact opposite is the truth and I
think that that's a very hopeful
realization because you don't have to
betray yourself or other people in order
to succeed but there is a definite fear
among people that they're going to be
found out you know if you're if you're
doing really really well they'll find
out that you're really not that good yes
and you know and that that really
terrifies people on what if I'm found
out but it's sometimes it's it ease
one's burden to know that that's what
most people feel that they're gonna be
found out no matter how firms are no
matter how for how long they're
eventually going to probably doubt for
not being that amazing well again this
is where it's so useful to to interview
these is hugely successful people he's
wonderful brilliant artists because you
see what happens when they have reject
rejections when they have
disappointments there was a there's a
there was this guy who I'm he want to be
a writer and he wrote a script and he
sold his script he'd had his first big
sale to the networks and so he went from
he travels from Ohio to New York to have
his first meeting with the producer and
the director and all the actors around a
table and he dressed up in a suit and a
tie and he had a briefcase and he went
in to meet with them and the meeting
went really well and he said everything
just right and and the meeting it came
to an end he shook their hand and he's
headed for the door and he was so
nervous that he missed the door walked
into the wall and dropped his briefcase
in his briefcase sprang open and his
socks and his underwear sprang out so
blushing blushing furiously blushing
furiously he gathered up he Ollis socks
and underwear put them back in the
briefcase tumbled out in the into the
corridor into the hallway and thought to
himself how can I ever face these people
again and the producer came out into the
hallway and put his arm around this
young writer and he said look little
friend all they care about is what you
have up here and the writer was Rod
Serling and that was the first
experience is enough in the hit in this
industry and so even rod had those
moments you know and of course he became
one of the great writers and one of the
great show runners and he didn't know he
didn't know he died at age 50 and in the
last interview he gave the reporter said
do you think your work will will last
and he said good writing like fine wine
has to age well with time
and he said I think my work has been
momentarily adequate so so he never knew
he never knew that Twilight Zone was
gonna be one of the great great shows
ever made well the greatest shows ever
made there would last and be even more
popular now than when it aired so it's
really dangerous to aim for great you
just say I'm going to do the very best I
can until the deepest truth I possibly
can and just see what happens well what
you have control over is what you create
well you don't have control over is how
it will be received you don't have
control over whether whether it will
last you don't have control over people
whether people will appreciate it
all you can do is say okay what's my
truth you know rod rod used to say when
he about his own writing he say is this
the truth as I know it or better yet as
I feel it well that's all we can do
really all we have is our authenticity
all we have is our truth in our story
which is what I always say two actors
Ben I used to coach you know actors and
it was like what is your most important
job with the first job and I get all
kinds of answers and I say well no your
most important job is to tell your truth
yes to tell the truth of your character
right whatever that is and because
that's what people will connect with and
share and and that's where we go out of
the you know out of the theater is
feeling a little less alone and a little
more connected because we recognize the
truth if you're not telling the truth
there's this real disconnect there was a
television show where the showrunner and
they were dealing with a very painful
subject which was sexual abuse of
children adults adult survivors and and
I was watching this clip of this show
and it felt completely bogus and I
thought and it was I thought well it's
important to have this on television
because people tend to feel very
isolated by these kind of ugly incidents
but but if you have it in an
exploitative fashion then it's the
opposite it has the opposite effect
doesn't make people feel more connected
or less shamed it makes people feel more
isolated because it's not their truth up
there and so I was quite offended by the
show not the topic but the way in which
it was handled and I said what research
did you do for this is it oh well we
just thought we could imagine what it
would be like and I thought now said you
know and that was really clear in this
show
and so I mean the truth is very very
important and if you don't know the
truth and you're going to present what
you want to be the truth we better you
better research it because this isn't a
joke well you know what you're talking
about yes you always yours your audience
you're being given a great privilege to
speak to hundreds of thousand one
hundred hundreds of thousands people
millions of people it's a great
privilege and if you lie well shame on
you you know it hurts people but also
you know and this guy was very very
successful and so it's not our
responsibility whether or not someone
else succeeds or not whether their work
is deserving or not it's our
responsibility to to tell our truth to
be to do our job that's all we have
control over you know and and then and
also it's very important know what's
what's a game you can't win so for
instance if you're pitching a story to a
network or a studio and that's not what
they want to make then the question
ultimately becomes how committed are you
to what you want to do because at the
end of the day you have to decide what
you're going to create and and if you
say okay because you know as I said we
mentor many many many people and we've
done so for many years and most people
give up at the slightest resistance and
it's very important if you're actually
going to create something worthwhile to
have a backbone you know and to say okay
look someone once asked me the secret of
my success and I said I don't give
myself an out that means that if I say
I'm going to do something I have to do
it instead and sometimes it's hard and
sometimes it's harder but it's it's
irrelevant if it's hard I mean it's just
what I take on and I'm committed to
doing it it's but it's also exhilarating
it's so much fun I love what I do
yes you don't want to ever hear somebody
say well they won't let me I don't know
today is yeah but but if if they're
imaginary playmate they may yes but but
if you know buyer a doesn't want it well
do your research and find buyer B and
buyer see well who does who is good with
that kind of time help you hit say it
well but also in the old days you know
when there were only three networks and
would cost millions of dollars and you
had to shoot on thirty five-millimeter
then there was an excuse if like for
instance Orson Welles you know the last
twenty years of his life he never got to
make a movie well that wasn't his fault
he was trying hard
it was just so expensive he was in an
art form that was crazily expensive but
nowadays when you can buy you know I
mean everyone has a camera in their
phone for God's sake if you want to make
something make it you know I'm in this
and there also is a question you know if
you want a career in Hollywood and by
Hollywood I mean sort of this this world
art form that we work in you have to say
well why don't what am I in it for am I
in it because I want to be rich because
I want that Hollywood dream of the big
house and the limousine well that's one
dream it's not my dream god knows or is
it that you want to create something to
share with the world well if it's the
latter then anytime you say well they're
not letting me do it it means that
you're just letting them stop you and
you're not saying okay what skills do I
need to learn well who do I need to
affiliate with what if you decide that
you're going to green-light yourself
then you're free but but of course you
know if you say they won't let me do it
then you've got your good excuse yes and
the question always is do you want to
live in the excuse would you want to
live in the in the action you know
because and again you know it's not for
us to say what someone else should do
but it's up to us to better than
attempting yeah but no but it's up to us
to be authentic and if we inspire others
that's great if someone hears any of
what we're saying and says well gosh let
me take a crack at this let me try you
know and and you know if you try and you
keep trying and you find the way through
the door then you know you usually do
quite well there was another friend of
mine who um he decided he wanted be the
greatest writer who ever lived
true story and he went to a psychiatrist
and after an hour of talking about this
stuff the psychiatrist said to this
young man he said well I think I can
cure you of this delusion so you should
come see me twice a week and my friend
left that session and decided instead of
doing that he would just go for it and
that was Ray Bradbury and he became of
course one of the greatest writers of
the 20th century and Ray told me that
story he was my mentor for over ten
years and so so again one man's delusion
is another man's great accomplishment
and what determines that often is just
the drive the drive you know I think
great once told me that his life was the
story of someone who decided he was
going to go somewhere and wet
going back to the idea for Space Command
so how long have you actually been
working on it since the very beginning I
like the idea the inception was like
1832 it was not via the initial idea for
Space Command came about in 2012 Oh and
year so it was a few years and but but
it was really in in germinating in my
head for a long long time because again
I wanted to create a hopeful vision of
the future I wanted to do for the modern
audience what Star Trek had done for me
as a kid and so I really was starting to
put the pieces together and also I was
collecting actors you know as in my
career in television I was you know
working on a lot of science fiction
shows and gathering a lot of actors that
I really wanted to work with again and
write roles for and you know I recently
did wrote a book with Guillermo del Toro
and I I won the Saturn Award a couple
years ago and I saw this amazing guy in
this in this Victorian coat this tall
thin guy really remarkable looking and I
went up to him - at the Saturn Awards to
congratulate him on look the coat and
how he looked and it was an actor named
Doug Jones and Doug is and pretty much
everything Guillermo does he played pan
and pence labyrinth and Abe Sapien and
Hellboy and he's in the strain and he's
in just pretty much everything crimson
peak and and he's been in tons of other
things he's the lead alien and falling
skies so we had lunch really hit it off
and as I told him I was gonna write a
role for him a lead and that's what we
did in Space Command and so so the the
crowdfunding campaign was in 2012 and
that and that along with his the
investment shares that we sold and her
still she is a continuing to sell gave
us the money to open our own studio and
then as I said I mention I wrote you
know the first 8 hours of the show and
out late hours 9 through 12 and Elena
and I have been actually co-writing on
this and and so that was this big
tapestry this great big canvas and and
so so just kind of grew and grew as I
started to know who the characters were
and what those story was I knew I wanted
to tell a multi-generational story and I
wanted to have a very a multi-national
multi-ethnic multiracial cast so our
actors are wise in black and Asian and
Latino and
actors come from Venezuela and Pakistan
and Sri Lanka all around the world and
and I cast many famous actors but we
also had a Talent Search where anywhere
anyone anywhere in the world
could download the audition scenes and
audition for two of our leads and we got
7000 enquiries in 1,200 videos and we
ultimately ended up casting six actors
from those from those auditions and
including our two of our leads and from
that from my oming from New York from
Iowa from there all over the place and
so Space Command kind of came together
in bits and pieces and it still and it
still comes it comes it's funny because
once you start shooting something the
actors and their performances and the
chemistry between them also is something
that starts to alter your vision you
start it becomes a dialogue between you
and them if you're if you're if you do
it well and and so then you say oh
here's an interesting way of doing it
here's an interesting way of having it
pay off
also because we jump back and forth over
five generations of our of our
characters there's four families and we
see the action and reaction we go back
and forth between that over 150 year
period and so so for instance the first
two our story takes place at one point
60 years from now and then the second -
our story takes place three years after
that and then at various points for
jumping 90 years later and coming back
so it's it's really this very
interesting tapestry that we get to see
so so I really love that I haven't seen
that before I haven't seen anyone else
do that it's very to see kick actors
develop an owner role yes and that
definitely does mold and usually deepen
you know you're starting to rewrite and
throw in extra scenes because they
themselves you just really step deeply
into the character you know and things
come alive that you hadn't seen you know
relationships come alive that you hadn't
seen and so the the talent hunt was
amazing because there's brilliant acting
all over the world
we only cast six people but we would
have liked to have cast a lot more they
just didn't quite fit the role as well
but they were fine actors all over the
country and so that was fun and it was
sold on the world all around the world
and it was really fun with doug jones
who is a wonderful actor but he usually
is almost like them
mine because he plays creatures right
but he has this he's a stunningly
beautiful man and and so in this we
finally get to see him and we get to see
what an extremely delicate and very
sensitive actor it got and so it's it's
grand to be able to you know give him
that stage and let the people let people
see what a what a consummate actually is
with very little makeup
well I there's an interesting thing that
happened on set we were shooting the
first chunk we've shot Space Command in
various chunks because we have a lower
budget then a studio film would have or
TV show we had to be very clever in how
we utilized our money so it was used
effectively so we shot four days of the
first two-hour story and then came back
several months later on some of the
other sets we built and shot the rest of
it and so the first several days we were
shooting all of Doug Jones's scenes and
Marilyn and bill Mumy and so forth and
there was a lot of dialogue to cover we
were shooting eight to twelve pages a
day and Doug was Doug Jones was very
nervous about being able to remember all
the lines even though with all of our
actors we had other actors with them to
just run the lines when they weren't on
you know when we weren't shooting oh
they were just just a camera to throw a
line we said look we can edit we can
edit never worry about dropping a line
because it will be thrown right back and
you can cut into it and well when when
we stop making them nervous when they
weren't nervous about it they usually
remembered their line was just nerves
that would throw send them up well what
I said - Doug was I said because he was
nervous about game lines and doing all
the lines and I said look we as Elaine
said we can we can pick it up it's not
about the lines I said we were here for
one purpose and one purpose only I said
you have an amazing soul and our job
here is to show the audience your soul
and that's all we're here to do and so
don't worry about the lines and the
irony was from there on he never blew a
line not once and so he was able to
relax but he did a phenomenal job his
performance is terrific and we're going
to continue with ongoingly to utilize
his character because we have two
viewpoint characters what I call
viewpoint characters over the hundred
and fifty years because most the
characters grow old an age and die and
so forth they have children and
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
but but Doug Jones is a synthetic a
synthetic human he's an Android a
replicant so he covers the entire 100
years as a viewpoint character and
mirror ferlyn plays a human but she's
been genetically altered where she's
very hard to kill she's practically
immortal and so again she'll be another
viewpoint character over that time frame
and and her characters also her
character has a daughter who hasn't been
genetically altered so she ages in a
normal time frame but and mirrors also
in a gay marriage she's married to a
woman because again I want the world of
space command to match the world I live
in and it was very interesting when
Sally Ride Sally Ride was the first
American female astronaut and it was
only when she died that they mentioned
her longtime companion and I said well
why didn't everyone know that she was
gay I mean why where they where they
gave women in science fiction where the
game women in science and it's I think
it's very important that we know that
that all these people that the world is
what the world is that it's inclusive
and I want Space Command to be inclusive
and so so that was that was very fun to
write that and have that in Space
Command as well as we have Muslim
characters we have all sorts of
characters and again to present the
commonality of humanity so that so we
don't see people as the other we see
them as ourselves what is this five year
pursuit taught you about dreams making
them happen setbacks coming back again
what does it taught you about a journey
of seeing something they evolve and and
come to life sure all of my major
projects I know going in will take years
so for instance when I wrote The
Twilight Zone companion which was my
first book that took five years from the
month I started as a month what came out
the book has been in print for over 30
years now and so and so and when I was
writing that someone said to me well
what are you gonna be done and I said
I'll be done when it's right and because
I took the time to make it right it
stood the test of time it lasted the
book I just wrote with Guillermo del
Toro it took me four years and during
during all these periods I'm working on
multiple projects I like to multitask I
like to do that many things at once
my new Space Command would be a massive
project the first two hours have the
first two our story has 1900 visual
effects shots
that's more than star wars and a big
episode of Battlestar Galactica would
have 200 there's do hunt 200 visual
effects shots this has
1900 in the first two hours so I knew
that would be incredibly ambitious and
but the steps in space command were
raised the money to get thing going
continue to raise money by selling
shares shoot the first two hours and
then lock down in a powerful agency that
then gives me the credibility to go and
pitch the networks and sell the show and
so all of those things are very
time-consuming and it's it's like a
military campaign so I knew it would
take years and and but we're further
along or closer to being toward the
finish line than toward the beginning
because we've shot you know two hours of
the shot the entire first story we've
shot 30 minutes of the second story and
and now I'm pitching the series and
whoever buys it will have to pick up the
first season and that's 12 episodes and
we're getting a very good response we're
you know but it comes from putting in
the work because now we can say this is
what this is this is what it looks like
here it is here's the thing itself and
and that's a great great experience
there's a truism about almost any
television show or film where everybody
then said if I'd known have been this
hard I never would have started it and
and and but that once you're in it you
can't turn around then they jump into
another project you know I so they had
no memory of what had just happened
right so I think you know some of it is
it is kind of a wild horse but when
you're on you're not too eager let go
but there are there are twists and turns
and our disappointments and certain
things you can't foresee for instance we
brought a board there was a visual
effects of genius that I'd worked with
many times in my career he'd won an Emmy
for Star Trek Voyager
he designed Babylon 5 and and and
reinvented television how visual effects
were done in television and he did the
Star Trek episode that I did with with
Lena and I did with George Takei we did
a few years ago that got nominated for
the Hugo and the nebula Awards so I
brought him aboard Space Command and he
fell ill and sadly died his name was Ron
Thornton and he was a genius but sadly
he didn't get to see yes through to the
finish line and that's just what life
does sometimes you know you never know
he he was only he was like 59 very sad
and so but again you just tries for
anyone who wants to produce I'm more
producer
that than mark mark you know billions
better and wiser than me in every way no
no I'm a detail person but I I always
say you know the thing is that some
people feel things are going awry that
they're not producing well which is
that's just what happens that's being a
producer so I try sourcing producing
anything is that as a spinning ball but
it's spinning very quickly and things
are flying off into space and your job
as a producer is to tack back things as
quickly as you can and always make the
assumption that the thing you're gonna
tack back on will be better than the
thing that swirled off into space
and you're not doing anything wrong
that's just the nature of production and
if you have that headset and you're not
like beating yourself up you're just
moving as fast as you can and keeping
your eye on the ball you'll be a much
happier producer right and also again
you know Elaine it's funny because some
because Elena and I've been together for
40 years and married for 39 and I've
worked together so much people assume
we're very similar but in reality were
very very different Elaine for one is
sane but but but serially she's calmer
than I am I'm a warrior I'm very my head
is very very busy I beat myself up a lot
but I'm the one with the big vision I'm
the one who well I'll take on something
that's crazily big for instance when I
wrote The Twilight Zone companion it was
- I started that book two years after
Rod Serling died and I had graduated
from UCLA with a degree in painting
sculpture graphic arts I had sold one
short story I had never sold an article
I had never taken the journalism class
and I decided I was gonna write a book
about the twilight zone
now I had already heard that Carol
Serling rods Widow had turned down major
journalists so if I had asked a hundred
people what my chance of getting Rod
Serling's Widow to let me do a book
about the twilight zone was a hundred
people would have said you have no
chance I was 22 years old but it's not a
majority opinion your fate is not
majority opinion you out vote the world
if you decide you're going to do
something and so then it just became
strategic it's like how do I go about
doing this so what I did was I met one
writer from The Twilight Zone one writer
from The Twilight Zone George Clayton
Johnson I met him when I was 16 years
old at a science-fiction convention and
we became friends so I interviewed him
about the Twilight Zone he connected me
up with two other people's work on the
show
interview them and over a three-month
period I interviewed 30 people who work
on the show then I went to Carol Serling
and by then I know a lot about the show
and I felt very confident that I could
do this book and so I went to her house
it was rods house it was exactly as rod
had left it
his Emmys were there six Emmys there was
one room just for the trophies and so
six Emmys three Hugo's the Peabody Award
all that stuff his dog was still there
the senile Irish Setter it all his
office was intact exactly as he left it
and and I remember standing in this huge
living room with Carol Sterling sitting
on the couch and for some reason I was
standing and I told her what I had in
mind and I could envision that future of
my completing the book successfully as
clearly as I see you and I spoke very
convincingly and I knew what I was
talking about cuz I'd done my research
and and she and she she talked to some
of the people I'd interviewed and the
people she knew and trusted and they
clearly gave me a good bill of health a
good rapport because she came back and
she said oK you've got full access to
everything and so I spent several years
crawling through rods attic and in his
garage there were the 16 millimeter film
film prints in these big film cans of
the Twilight Zone episodes I would take
home estate a stack like this and put
them on the projector they had the
original commercials the coming
attractions spots now and some of these
prints had never even been through a
projector and and I wrote the book and
so so that but it was a crazily
ambitious project as well as his space
command and I actually enjoy big
challenges it's been old enough in time
as a test yeah well you know that was
another crazy thing to do it was um
that was sort of the test run as Elaine
said it was basically I was at a
science-fiction convention and this is
just when's the Star Trek and when
Enterprise was kind of fading it was
dying down the fans hadn't really
embraced it and and this is before JJ
Abrams said he was going to do the Star
Trek movie and so this I was on a panel
for Star Trek so I wrote for Star Trek
The Next Generation in Deep Space nine
and someone from the audience said well
what's the future of Star Trek and
Walter Keenan could play Chekov gave
this answer and it was a crazy answer it
was so crazy that I afterwards I said
tell me all about this and I talked to
him for about an hour and he told me
that there were a group of fans in
upstate New York who had bill
a full-size copy of all the original
Star Trek sets from the blueprints they
were shooting their own Star Trek
episodes and putting them online and
they were getting a larger audience than
Enterprise was getting on UPN and he was
about to fly to New York and be in an
episode starring himself as Chekov and
written by DC Fontana Dorothy Fontana
who had written a story edited the
original Star Trek series so that night
I went online they had an episode of
that they had done which was a sequel to
an episode the original Star Trek had
done called the doomsday machine and it
had William Windom who had been in that
the guest star in that episode and it
was it was great fun and so I friend of
mine years ago had come up with a great
Sulu episode they were gonna bring Star
Trek back in the 70s paramount was and
then Star Wars came out and after year
of development they made the movie
instead the series they'd been
developing and so my friend had pitched
to them a great Star Trek episode strong
Sulu and it didn't get made and both he
and I had written for Star Trek The Next
Generation he was an Emmy winner and I
called him an I said one write this
episode he said sure you know the two of
us and so I called the boys in upstate
New York and I said hey we wanted this
Sulu episode and I want to direct it
because I'd always wanted to direct and
they said sure and I said but we have to
shoot high def they'd been shooting mini
DV and they said yeah well if you can
get the cameras and I said okay and then
I went to George Takei and I sat in his
kitchen his living room actually drunk
dining room and and I gave him I type of
three-page outline of what the story
would be and I said you never got the
great Sulu episode you deserved this is
it I need you to tell me if you'll do it
so he sat there and he read the three
pages he said I'm in so we spent six
months building our production team we
shot nine days in upstate New York on
the enterprise sets we built Sulu ship
the the idiom what's it called the Sulu
ship the Excelsior yes it's the
Excelsior so we built Sulu ship the
Excelsior here in LA so we shot two days
here in LA and one day in Florida with
the effects team it was a solid year of
post-production 700 visual effects shots
it's called Star Trek world enough in
time you can actually watch it on my
website Mark Zachary comm in its
entirety and it got nominated for the
Hugo nebula which are the two top awards
in science fiction first time any
independent project had ever been
nominated for those awards we did it
without a studio or a network we did it
for under 100
and dollars and and it looked as good as
any Network show you'd ever see and and
I showed it I said to George when we
were shooting a year from now you and I
will be at the world science fiction
convention in Japan we'll be showing
this to an audience of several thousand
people and at the end will answer
questions I'll be speaking in English
you'll be speaking in Japanese because
he's fluent and and I said a year later
we'll be nominated for the Hugo and all
of that stuff came true and and when we
showed it in Japan there was three
thousand people in the audience and we
got a standing ovation people who were
in tears at the end because it was so
moving and and so you know so I say I
had that vision I was I was speaking a
future that I made happen and then but
the fact that I was able to do that
without a studio or a network it showed
that I could create something without
that infrastructure and that showed me
that I could do space command and that
that gave me the credibility to pull it
off if that all sounds so smooth in the
telling there were quite a few bumpy
bits as we were doing this yeah
the team got very worried about high-def
the initial team because they were very
worried that that it would show a
multitude of flaws in their sets which
it did not I mean the cells were
beautiful but there was a lot of concern
about hi-def which they then used from
then on but there were many and the
acting of the initial team who had put
it together they were fans they needed a
little bit of polishing for some of them
some of them are pros some of them were
not and they were they were good enough
to be enthusiastic about actor camp
which we set up so we had an actor camp
but there were a lot of little Hurst
with them we were here we did improv we
did we want to see who had the strongest
acting chops of the engine they were
very open to to learning so that the one
who's playing Captain Kirk fellows
playing Captain Kirk who was okay he was
fine you know but but at one point he
was like really eager he was working and
he got applauded after she one scene
that he done and then he was really you
know with the with the learning curve so
but but there was a lot of tension you
know people were being pressed to come
to a different to a really high level
and and that's where I was you know my
job was being the H HDH which was the
hothead D ha to fire when people were
starting to get a little bit tense
very intense on the ocean it can and he
was just driving and driving and driving
it so it was and the final day you
should talk about George Takei on that
final day well it was just he was just
amazing we shot a very very long day and
the last take he did was one taken it
was perfect and how many hours was that
20 years like a 20-hour day and he was
up there nominal after a 20-hour date
never complained yeah and we'd spent
months lifting weights and getting in
shape he lost 15 pounds and he wasn't in
bad shape oh my god integrated in it and
then he was then on cue after like a
20-hour day he was standing on that
stage while the traffic on the
transporter stage with a single tear
tracking down his face exactly on cue
well that was appropriate than scene it
wasn't it was no no because he ended
working between oh thank you he was just
he was just phenomenal so there was a
tremendous pressure so I mean there are
a lot of stories but so it wasn't easy
it's never easy but have to be crazily
driven yes you have to just be the
engine that doesn't stop and and that's
when you have a calling that's when you
I mean if you're doing it for the wrong
reasons if you're doing it because you
want to prove something to your parents
or you want to you know as I said make a
lot of money or you want to just kind of
do crap work and have that somehow slide
by those are all the wrong reasons you
know there's a friend of mine his name's
Frank Spotnitz he was executive producer
through the x-files he created and ran
man in the high castle and he's got four
shows on the air right now and he said
good enough is never good enough and I
absolutely believe that but with these
fans they were like really driven they
were doing it out of love
and even if they can hang greet each
other you know there's never enough time
there's never enough resources you're
always trying to protect your department
against other department people right do
your best job but but there's still for
all the the tensions they were a delight
to work with because they were doing
what they loved thinking back to
something a mentor said to the two of
you individually maybe even before you
met one another what was it and what is
it what statement was that or mantra
that never left you could be Ray
Bradbury could be sure I I if anything
but the thing that most affected me was
a scripture a very good script doctor
that I had
and and and there was a script I'd
written when I was one of my favorite
scripts ultimately but but she said this
is brilliant
I absolutely love it now here's the
notes and and but but the fact that she
said that I was brilliant and that she
loved it I thought well what the heck
with a few notes I'm brilliant and I
loved it so I think you know crazy
flattery you know I really sort of the
weight of allowing somebody to be feel
special and be special with crazy
flattery that all those notes seemed
like nothing so you know one of the
biggest biggest pieces of advice was
that hey you know what you're doing has
super value now here's the work and just
going on that thing where I was allowed
to have super value at the top of the
journey really got me through I thought
it was nothing that was nose um in terms
of of me the mentors were they've told
me you know it's funny because you know
the the mentors really who've guided me
have been you know Rod Serling Ray
Bradbury Guillermo del Toro and what
really inspired me was the fact that
these are guys who just come from
enormous enthusiasm creative enthusiasm
and raise one thing Ray said to me was
he said don't look outside yourself look
within and so it's again finding I
divided funny there was one time when he
and I were sitting together and I said I
just figure out what business you're in
I said it's not writer I said you're in
the Ray Bradbury business and he said
yes that's exactly right and what he so
what he was doing was creating something
that no one else could create and he
told me that he spent he wrote every day
for ten years before he wrote a single
line a single word that was uniquely his
and then one day he sat down and he
wrote the words the lake and he wrote a
short story based on the time when he
was a little boy when he was 8 years old
he and a little girl friend who was 7
when swimming in Lake Michigan and he
came out and she never did she drowned
and it was a story of had her coming
back as a ghost and he told me that when
he finished this story tears were
streaming down his face and he knew he
had written something that no one else
could have written it came specifically
from his
experience and his soul and he said it
took me and it took another two years of
writing every day before he could write
something again that was uniquely his
and they got to where he could do it
again and again and again and he became
Ray Bradbury because he was determined
to do that and so I thought that was a
great lesson to say okay what are you
creating what can you create that isn't
something that's just an imitation what
others are doing
but that's unique to you that no one
else could have created that you create
something fresh in the world that's
truthful and meaningful and and then you
know you've done something worth doing
so that's that's been a great
inspiration to me there's been so many
people because they're so afraid of
being heard they they do the safe thing
so that somebody says that's not very
good they say I know it was a piece of
trash I was teaching everybody else was
doing so you do put yourself out for a
far greater vulnerability but then with
something original something you mean if
you do something original but then to
not do so is slowly slow so slowly
soul-killing
yeah see that quickly I I failed to say
it quickly I I all over my yeah
so yes it is it's like being worn down
by the ocean you just does and so one of
the things like as an example when we
work together for TV if we got a note it
wouldn't matter if it's a dumb note or
not sometimes the notes were great but
sometimes the notes were John and we
made a pact that no matter how dumb they
don't felt initially we would not hand
in that draft until we were able to work
that note in in a way which made it
better so every draft had be better than
the previous draft and so no matter how
challenging the notes were we would find
the way to do that and my foot my friend
Doug Hayes who was one of the great
directors of the twilight zone he did I
the beholder in the after hours and the
howling man many other episodes he he
was also very good writer and he said
when you get notes the executives giving
the notes are often not writers and so
the note the solution they're offering
may not work but that there's a concern
under the note there's something that's
not working for them and what they're
saying the solution is may not be the
right solution and never put in
something in your script that doesn't
work but you have to look at what the
concern is you have to figure out what
the concern is and address that and if
you come up with an alternative that
does work they'll be satisfied even if
the solution they are
it isn't the one that you utilized as
long as the concern is addressed and
that was a great piece of wisdom so you
really want to maintain a pride of
workmanship and not just say oh you know
you never never taught us at all first
of this know that you don't do that to
the audience give it you give it your
best because it represents you when you
make it represent you and you you see do
that on people on like an assembly lines
where you develop something you don't
care versus something you care about and
you take a little bit of you're allowed
a little bit of pride in what you do
which i think is just critical to the
way humans work and so yes we would put
up that fight but it like I always
remember she's a you know when we're
teaching there was a woman who shared
with me she had a an action piece he's
man and woman in this action thing and
it was like non-stop action non-stop
action going and going going and the
woman said who was the executive well it
sort of drags in the second act it
really drags and she flared but you
enough to keep it to herself and said
well let me look at that it was dragging
in the second act and saying how could
it drag is like there was non-stop
action and then it hit her on the way
home
that it wasn't it was non-stop action
it's that in act one she had not set up
us caring sufficiently about the leads
and the outcome for those leads for us
to care what kind of threat they were
facing because we didn't care and so she
said okay well she's going to like
deepen the characters and much more
focus on their need and our investment
in their journey she's going to slow
down the second act still keeping it
exciting but she's going to slow it down
so that we really know what the struggle
is about and the reason that they went
that it seemed slow was we just didn't
care
and the the executive then said this is
much better now it really rolls along
now she couldn't analyze why she didn't
care in the second - but she was dead on
by the second deck we were getting
rested and simply didn't care because we
didn't know who was in the struggle and
so why would we care so sometimes they
don't communicate what's really going on
they just know that it's falling flat
yeah it's not their responsibility to
make the script work it's your
responsibility and so they've hired you
because you're
writer and and so they mean everyone you
know what you know executives get a bad
rap most of them are very smart and very
talented and very driven and they're in
the business business because they love
it and everyone wants a script to work
everyone wants a movie to work nobody
wants to create something that fails and
so but it's very challenging I mean it's
it's hard to make anything good and so
but but if you decide that you're going
to give everything your best effort that
you're gonna bring everything you've got
to every job that's a good starting
point and and so that's been true in my
whole career yeah I started an animation
and whether it was writing Smurfs or
space command I mean it's and I don't
just write things with an S starting the
title but but you know you you say okay
I'm going to I'm gonna bring everything
I've got to this and that that gives you
a certain professional integrity and yes
the the executives that they're paid to
get a sense of a story but you're paid
because you have the analysis in your
brain as to accept okay there's
something wrong I have to figure out
what is wrong specifically but they've
picked up that something is wrong and
they're probably accurate but sometimes
you'll need to have that's where it's
good have friends who are very talented
so that if you're stuck you can call
them and say look can we just Beth
sitting around a little bit I got to
figure this out and and Elaine is my
sounding board so for instance and
sometimes it'll be like okay this works
but how can we make this better how can
we go deeper how can it be more
meaningful and that's a very important
what's the biggest obstacle or setback
you feel that each of you has faced
personally in your careers you don't
have to be specific in terms of what
project but just in terms of how you
work through it I think that it's it's
rarely a setback it's the it's that you
get tired sometimes you get tired and
when you get tired then things start to
hit you and you cannot see a way around
you know whereas if you got a good
night's sleep sometimes it's easy
sometimes it's hard I think it's the
wear and tear and that's where you
really have to say never get into this
life alone you know get get you always
have somebody to back you up a
or or you know in this case we have a
spouse who's a friend well I also that
table when we have yeah we have the
table which we talked about in one
second but the whole thing is to say
this whole thing about rugged
individualism and by your bootstraps
that's just not the way people operate
you know it's one of my favorite songs
is lean on me and you know and you know
and someday I'll need someone to lean on
and I think that's really true so it's
it's the day-to-day grind you know the
you you always we hope for something
sometimes this how folks are higher than
mine so I don't have this big setbacks
because I'm always a little more wary
than he is I don't like oh this is great
old you know so it's like I'm much much
you know it's a bigger hit when it goes
down but but still it's that you know if
you don't expect to if you you know
there's somebody you can turn to and say
I'm just down today it's just I just had
a bad day and someone can say it's it's
okay you've got the you know somebody
can just say it's okay keep going that
that's the big I'd say just dealing it
with it with other people is the trick
and don't don't lock it down you were
going to talk about the table well yeah
I mean we run this roundtable of writers
and directors and actors and producers
and editors and composers etc that
several thousand people we've been
running it every Thursday for 24 years
and it's to create a compassionate
community in Hollywood and now we have
offshoots all over the country and again
it was because I wanted to create the
Hollywood I wanted to live in and and
Hollywood can be very corrosive it can
wear you down you have to really be very
careful of who you're giving judgement
to who's in judgment of you at where you
internalize that because if you if it's
people who are hateful who are toxic or
cruel that can destroy you and so you
have to you have to surround yourself
with people who are loving people who
are kind and it's it's hugely important
and because at the end of the day you
have to build a life the life is
ultimately more important than this
script or this project or any of it you
have to have a life where you're loved
and you're loving where you have enough
people who as Lance and when you fall
tour will be there for you and again it
has to be
lean on me is good if it's if it's going
both ways
it isn't like well let me drain your
lifeforce and leave you an empty husk
you know which is what some people do
you know and so you have to make sure
that it's it's a reciprocal and that's
not what we with the round table that we
run that's what we teach and even the
classes we teach where we mentor people
what we often say is your career will be
defined by two poles what you stand for
and what you won't stand for but you
have to know what those two things are
and and a lot of people particularly
actors actors can end up being very
successful but feeling very empty
because they're doing roles that are not
not an alignment with what they
themselves believe and so you have to
decide well what do I believe what is
meaningful to me and then how can I do
work that speaks from that and speaks to
that and because they can there's a
habit of executives who are not artists
just sort of project who the hell are
you you know and it's very hard to
answer that but if you know what you
stand for like if you say I said what I
take a stand for the message that I'm
going to give is that as long as you
keep trying as long as you're in the
game then your hero you know let's say
that's what you want to stand for and if
I say well who the hell are you you say
I'm the person who stands for this
message and it's an important message
and they can't get to you in that way if
you really aren't clear on what you
stand for but but sometimes it's always
hard and the good thing about like at
the table let's see if me they see
you advertised I made five calls and
it's five knows but but then you're
getting applause for having picked up
the phone five times and then you make
five more calls the next day you get
applauded for going to you know keep
your going in the game you're you're
still fighting on and I think that we
all sort of need that it you say hey I
made five calls I'm gonna make five
calls tomorrow it's okay that's what it
takes it takes a hundred calls to get
the one yes but I'm going to make those
hundred calls I'm gonna get that yes and
it's very interesting if you track how
people have struggled that my favorite
films if you listen to like the
filmmakers well they took them ten years
to get it mounted it took you know lots
of insults it took people you know
battering them down but they ended up
making something brilliant which a lot
of people didn't see but they saw and
and they gifted me with it so
I think that it's more realistic to say
hey let's let's applaud each other for
the effort well and also you know there
was a questions asked earlier about well
you know Space command's taken five
years so far and but the lovely part is
we now have a completed rough cut of the
first two hours and we're generating the
visual effects on the first two hours
now and so we get to watch the story
beginning to end and it's a wonderful
story in the and the actors are quite
wonderful in the performances are great
and the story is meaningful so that's
very heartening as well once you there's
a very missing dividing line between
when you have when you have the footage
and when you don't before you shoot
before you have the fit of the footage
in the can everything can conspire to
have the thing not exist so if you stop
before you've actually shot the film or
the pilot or whatever it is then it has
in it it's in great danger of never
existing the moment you shoot the moment
you've got it in the can then it simply
becomes bringing bringing assets to bear
to finish that's just about visual
effects color correction sound design
those are very doable but you've got the
story it exists it's like if you write a
novel if you finish the novel at least
there's a book that's beginning to end
you know and then you can refine it it's
no one will know how long you talked
about it yeah right to write it but it's
it's very important to finish what you
start because first of all if you finish
what you start you know you can finish
what you've started and and again again
another enemy is perfectionism you don't
want to have perfectionism stopped you
from starting or stop you from finishing
you know it's very important to finish
things and then refine Ray Bradbury who
who was my mentor for over 10 years his
when he wrote he would describe it as
vomit then mop which means you write you
pour it out then you refine it but you
start by pouring it out without judgment
and in his in his youth what he would do
is he would write he would sit down on a
Monday write an entire short story in
one sitting then Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday he would refine it
Friday he would mail it off and then
Monday he would start all over again he
was writing fifty stories a year and an
amazing output and actually he he kept
the same writing schedule for 70 over 70
years he was an amazing man
and and a great a great inspiration yeah
I was very lucky that I got to know him
and I'd go over to his house once a
month for over ten years and we just
talked about life and art and career and
and I'm actually writing a book now
called my Ray Bradbury that's about my
friendship with Ray because he told me
many things that were never never in
print never published and I'm thrilled
to be able to share that and of course a
few key members of our team told us not
to start shooting on our start time for
Space Command oh yeah well that's you
know again sometimes you're too very
careful of listening to people who are
faint of heart because a big part of
finishing anything is having the daring
to start you know because again once
something is in existence once it's in
motion momentum is enormous ly helpful
because then people see that the train
is moving and then they often want to
jump on board because something's
actually happening you know a lot of
people they're all talk a lot of people
flake you really have to look at it look
around you say okay who finishes what
they start who actually is serious about
this and affiliate with those people
because there's an energy that leads
towards success and there's an energy
that leads toward failure and you really
have to be mindful of that and observant
and again this is why I've surrounded
myself with you last night at the table
I was mentioning that I collect show
runners now the show runner is the
executive producer who runs a network
show but I do collect these people I do
get to know like if someone's doing the
show that I love I'll reach out to them
I'll go to an event I'll meet them and
then we form a friendship and a lot of
these people are my my mentors they're
my advisors they're my friends and it
goes both ways
so they'll ask me for advice it's funny
I was having lunch a few weeks with a
dear friend of mine who's run a number
of shows he's also a very talented
director and writer and he had just sold
a pilot and he was do you just couldn't
get the story to work so I said listen
is okay if I asked you and just walk
through this with you and so we talked
he said this is this is what the story
is but here's all the things I don't
know and I said oh well that's easy and
I just said okay here's how it goes and
within about I don't know 20 minutes we
totally work the thing out did that but
he you know he had the courage and the
confidence in himself to be able to say
I don't know how this goes
and can you help me and it is not paying
me I'm not being hired and that's fine
it's a two-way street the great thing
about Shakespeare and love
yes what the well what Shakespeare went
to another writer to ask to work through
a story point and that's why Shakespeare
in Love yeah that's right we both you
know really liked that story poem
because any writer knows that you end up
frequently bouncing on to other people
yeah
yes because again it's not about being
perfect it's about getting the job done
when you finish a screenplay what is the
standard protocol of steps you'll go
through after it's done the first thing
is to there are things to figure out
when it's done yeah and and so after you
finish the first draft it's very sad
when you when you're new to the job and
you finish your first draft and you
think it's done and of course the first
draft you're not even listening that the
end is off in the beginning yes it is
but so the first thing that you do is
you put it aside for a little bit and
then you reread it and I tend to give it
like I read it through several times for
one I read it through the seat does the
plot have Drive I'm just focusing on the
plot are there any big holes is this
does the piping go together
the next thing is I'll read it through
each character and say am i following
the journey of this character oh my gosh
how does she find that out why she
reacting to something she was never told
you know things like that you find out
those things or suddenly you you know
you lose sight of the character that is
suddenly kind of falling flat and so you
start to say okay what is the investment
in their journey you clarify each
character and you make sure that they're
consistent throughout and their voice is
consistent throughout and the final path
is a theme pass where let's say your
theme is you you really can't do
anything completely alone you can't live
your life alone and lead a productive
life and then you'll be going along and
suddenly another scene says oh you
should bootstrap yourself up and yeah
well that's a valid thing to say you
know stand on your own two feet but if
it's in the same movie you're certainly
jarred so the ideal you can't do it
every time but the ideal is to invent in
each scene you advance plot and
character and
theme you should see and should advance
those three things and for particular
scene seems to be falling flat usually
one of those things has been left out
and so so I read for those three things
and when that feels pretty good and I
put it aside then but we try and have is
like a reading what you know we sit
around the table and you read it and
then you hear things that you hadn't
heard before so basically it's that you
start testing the waters with it and at
first it's like difficult because you
think you're finished but if you have a
little bit of experience then the fifth
draft is far much more fun than the
first draft because you start to
discover things you start to develop
resonances and and connective tissue and
you've done the plumbing the real hard
work is done or let's say the technical
work and so that's where the fun work
starts where you can really hone moments
that you hadn't seen in the beginning
and so I think for me it's never done
until final post-edit mmm but you're
still finding things and seeing things
so you and the actors are discovering
things and you discover things in the
editing process so done is a very tricky
water well well so there's another
factor is you have to make sure where
the script that the main character is
driving it so in other words you have to
be very careful that the supporting
characters aren't the main character
though the main character isn't passive
very important and also there's always a
question of am i writing this script to
sell it or am i writing the script to
make it those are two totally different
objectives and there's also a reading
draft so in other words with some
scripts I've written I'll write them
where they're entertaining reads so in
other words the the description is as
entertaining as the dialogue because
someone's gonna be sitting and reading
it but you want them to be entertained
and delighted and ideally by the script
but there's other drafts that you're
writing to shoot like for instance with
Space Command I know I'm gonna be
shooting it that Elaine and I are going
to be directing it and that we're
producing it so then it's about well
okay how are we gonna build this how are
we going to design this who's who am i
hiring to do this role so I'm writing it
for students one of the things I do is
even whenever I write a script I cast it
in my mind
if it's certain actors I know I'm gonna
be hiring I'll cast them or sometimes
ugly actors who are just very
distinctive in my head or people from my
life were a very distinct of my head and
then I'll print out little photos of
them and I'll put them in a strip and
I'll put them on the computer in front
of me so that when I'm writing I can
look at that person's face and I can
hear them in my head
and and that make that makes it come
alive but but but often when I'm writing
this nowadays see right now in my life I
have zero interest in development I'm
not writing scripts to be put in
development and never made I'm not
writing scripts I'm here to make stuff
that's well and so that's why I did
Space Command the way I've done it and
gone directly to my audience so for me
it's very much ok we you know we're
gonna be shooting this so how do we how
do we make the costumes how do we build
the sets what's gonna make these look
interesting this is where my art
background comes in very handy because I
love working with visual designers and
all of that and but like one of the
things we have a challenge we have right
now is for the second film we've shot 30
minutes of it we have another the rest
of it to shoot and that takes place on
an alien spaceship a sleeper ship 300
people have been abducted by an alien
creature and put in hibernation so it's
like okay well that's interesting
because first of all how do we do it so
it looks different from anything we've
ever seen how can we utilize perhaps
what we have already and how can we make
it look very very interesting so we we
recently put some of our sets in storage
so we're not paying the overhead on us
on a soundstage that we had our own
physical studio for several years and so
I saw we have a cave set and in the
first space command film the first to
our story that case that was used for a
mining operation on series which is a
planetoid in the asteroid belt it was
used for Mars colony and it was used he
said that and then the second film used
it for ice caverns on Mercury this it's
ice because there's actually a crater on
Mercury that that's so deep that there's
ice at the bottom of it this is real
this is true scientific fact the Sun
never melts the ice and so I posited
having a city made of ice mercury has a
lot of iron on it so it's a so we have
this religious commune that mines the
iron and ships it to the outer planets
and so there they're there and they have
a city in the ice so we used our cave
set for the ice cavern so I thought well
you know we could take that cave set
turn it sideways painted black run LED
lights along it put oblong amber pieces
of lucite in it have that be the sleeper
cells do forced perspective to make it
look like there's 300 of them and Bane
we've got an alien spaceship so now
we're starting to think about how to
design that but in terms of like the
writing and what he said what was
important in terms of the hero that it
has to be the hero's journey yes because
people make a lot of mistake with their
leads they try and make them too shiny
bright and so they're boring and all we
want to see is the villain right we've
all seen those movies and and you start
giving too many of the fun lines to your
subsidiary characters right and you
don't really think through one the power
of the lead and really say okay what if
he were actually human and not all
polished and perfect because we all
secretly hate those people right and and
so you know what really is a struggle
what there's the external stuff but you
also have to give them the internal
stuff you know what what are the
insecurities what are the demons what
you know all these things and are we
really going to is that journey core
where we'll really get onboard with this
guy and do we really like this man and
have his journey so I mean you I I fell
afoul of like giving my my little side
characters too much fun like with the
one that the script doctor gave me all
these notes there was one little
character where I gave him so much fun
stuff and it kept slipping more and more
over to the hero more and more until
finally when my agent read it he said I
really like it but what's this character
doing in here I said oh nothing anymore
and so the my favorite character was it
was plucked out because he didn't really
belong because it wasn't about him
it wasn't about his journey it was about
the struggle of the two leads in this
particular piece so some of us to really
say what what am I trying to say and why
have I selected this character to take
the journey with and what will I love
about and one of my favorite films which
many people haven't seen because I'm
older is a thing called Marty and the
hero was a an ugly butcher like the
writer he the rider so him selves
you know from New York a chives penny
chefs key and he wasn't but that's how
he perceived himself and and so what is
the what's the heroic journey of his
character heroic journey of this
character is simply in the end to stand
against peers and family to go on a
quest for love because he just wants
someone to love him and people are under
you know mom doesn't want to be left
alone and the friends don't want to be
you know feel like losers because their
friend is married just well-meaning
people but in the end they were like
standing in opposition to him finding
someone that he really loved right and
and we can see that it took minced
courage to stand against your peers
understand against your family it was
small but it's huge its core and so I
found that an immensely touching piece
that this man who was passed marriage'
belayed fought to find something that he
really really wanted and but but he was
full of flaws he was afraid he he was
sweaty zhilie swayed and he you know he
he he was you know easily embarrassed
but he was a sweet and honorable man and
he found love and I found that an
extremely heroic piece of writing so
because we have our own studio now the
final draft of the script is actually
the final cut of the film
so we basically will write something
bring together our actors shoot it and
then refine it him in the cut and so we
love the fact that that allows us to
refine the story refine the script
refine what we had in mind and and often
they'll be discoveries along the way so
we love the entire part of the process
and a big part of it is just when you
meet brilliant wonderful people collect
them absorb them have them become part
of your team that's what I've done with
actors that's what I've done with our
editor who's terrific you know we just
find incredibly talented people and it's
not about Malayan said earlier you can't
be a one-man band if you were gonna just
if you wanted to be the end-all and the
be-all be a novelist because they can
sit in their room they can write they
can be these pale sad creatures but if
you're in film and TV you it takes
hundreds of people and then you need to
really be a leader have a vision be kind
to your people be supportive of them
if you're a monster if you're a
nightmare life's too short you know you
can't see people well your your actors
create a world your deity creates a
world yes you set designer creates a
world right but one thing I want to
mention is our job as directors see
Elaine is a better director than I am so
you know she's an actress director and
so we were very strong together as
directors we don't disagree on the set
because we see we have the same vision
but the our job is to make a safe place
for our actors so they can be vulnerable
they felt vulnerable they can be in the
moment our job is to give them the the
room to do what they need to do which is
find honest honesty and authenticity and
so we see very much eye-to-eye on that
yeah they have a very hard job because
they have to you know it when you're
writing you have to like say oh this
woman was betrayed and you have to live
through that betrayal once but you
expect you're a performer to do it over
and over and over and really feel that
and really be in the moment and that's
really really hard you have to be like
an Olympian you have to be entrained
have your emotions trained like an
Olympic runner that you can keep
summoning that over and over it's it's
terrible to have an actor sobbing and
say older sound hold her sound I mean
it's a terrible thing but really
well-trained dad yeah can do that I can
pull it out all well that's why I just
have to be in class they have to be
working on their craft they have to be
able to turn it on like that to be able
to do it over and over and over so yeah
you would say something earlier about
when you did the Space Command auditions
and you really saw people own the
character what is that when you cease
maybe you don't see it at first on that
same actor for that care and then that
there's a switch what is that owning how
do you want the owning of the character
is that they seem to be profoundly and
deeply inside the character and
fractured they know about the thing
about where either you're you know
either you're looking outside at
yourself and saying I'm this character
supposed to be angry I think I'll clench
my fists and I'll tighten my mouth and
I'll be angry and that always comes
across as phony but when a carrot when
somebody owns it it doesn't matter what
they're doing with their body or their
face inside the
very angry and one ticket may come out
loud one quietly but the camera really
sees your eyes rather sees it in your
eyes okay so they're they're actually
feeling it completely in the moment and
that's when you say they're owning it
because the what they're doing with I
mean their hands will naturally tense
but just mean they'll be doing this kind
of thing it means that you will when
they feel that you feel it when they
don't feel that you don't feel it it's
not in the same way and I've had you
know I've tested that out with actors
and and classes okay say okay when when
when did when were they feeling it in
the class of also at this time they were
feeling or the actor and say what were
you feeling it was always the same the
the camera sees when when it's real for
you
and that's owning the character and you
you often bring a really fine actor
brings a tremendous amount of their own
background and experience to it so they
not just own it but at the moment but
they own it in complex ways there's
sense memories and fears and if it was
supposed to be portrayed they remember
when they were to somebody mocking them
and not them not be able to stop the
tears and all of that actually comes
across in the moment on screen we go
back to the first screenplay ever sold
mm-hmm how did you do it what was the
process mmm well it's interesting
because you know people talk about talk
to me about you know how do you break
into Hollywood nice I always say I'm
like a burglar working a neighborhood
where I have to break in and break in
and break in it's a continual process
and the first script you know the first
script I sold interestingly enough was I
am against the speaks were gravitating
toward your heroes when I was an
undergraduate UCLA I was an art student
and one of my great heroes was going to
be teaching an adult education class at
UCLA his name was Theodore sturgeon he
was a writer from the original Star Trek
he did two great episodes of Star Trek
shore leave in amok time and he also had
written novels and short stories not
grown up reading him and idolizing me
idolizing him he was a brilliant writer
and so as an undergraduate I was
forbidden to take adult education
classes and I thought well you know
screw that I'm not going to miss this
opportunity
so I took the class and Ted sturgeon
became one of my great friends and meant
I was 19 years old and and his teaching
assistant was a young man named Michael
Reeves and Michael Reeves was selling
short stories and novels and he was just
breaking in his writing animation for
television and we became friends and he
at one point he was writing a show
called space stars for NBC it had space
ghosts in it and he was writing all of
them and he said you want to write one
of these with me and I said sure and so
we wrote that together and then Smurf's
was just starting up and so we wrote an
episode of Smurfs together and then it
was very clear I could write those on my
own and so I started writing for
animation so Smurfs and Superfriends and
he-man and Real Ghostbusters on and on
tons of shows and I became the god of
animation now I'd never wanted
particularly to be an animation writer
but that was my way in and so I was
writing for CBS and NBC and ABC and I
learned how to write on deadlines how to
write us to a specific page count right
character voice that was in tune with
what the voice of the show was and the
voice of the characters how to structure
stories all the things I would need to
write live-action TV shows and movies I
was learning my craft in animation and
meantime I during that period I was
writing The Twilight Zone companion so I
was learning that side of things too so
then I could earn $100,000 in just a few
months writing for animation so I
decided that I would then write a spec
live-action script as a showpiece get
into live-action
so I told all my employers that I was
going to take a break to write these
that my live-action samples feature and
they said fine and then as soon as that
date came they started calling me with
offers of work and I had to turn down
$200,000 worth of work in two days and
that was your writing day and and so I
then went to UCLA to write the library
and this is before cellphones so I could
write no one would bother me and at the
end of the day I would call in for my
messages and but I finished that
screenplay it's sold there's a
live-action script it then was then that
was used as a writing sample that got me
a pilot deal at NBC and I wrote that
pilot and that pilot got shot and then
from then on I was working in
live-action so that led to all the shows
I did on staff Friday the 13th the
series and slider
and on and on and on and so the moral of
that story is you have to stand for
yourself if you say you you're committed
to doing something committed to a
certain dream don't let people deflect
you from that dream because I could
easily have taken that animation work
and stayed I could be talking now and
still be an animation I could be writing
whatever the current animation shows are
and feeling very like I never had my
dream I never got to do what I wanted to
do instead because I was willing to turn
down that money and stand up for myself
and put in the work I now have my own
studio and I'm shooting what I'm here to
be shooting what I'm this is my dream
project and and I'm very grateful to
have had that opportunity but that was
that's been my journey why did I just
started out in theatre I started out
making stuff because I came from acting
like you might've acting got seduced by
the highs you have as an actor but it
really wasn't for me I was much more
comfortable behind the camera so I got
flattered I've got a lot of flattering
comments in terms of my skills in
theatre but I really preferred the
writing side so I started writing
reviews and putting those things on
yours
that kind of thing and so I just started
with making but also because as an actor
I was brought up in a very political
environment and you couldn't really
control the material and message was
extremely important to me whereas when I
started doing reviews I could put the
message out and this was you know a
while back and bad things were happening
so I did that and then when we got
together he seduced me into television
yes and so we started co-writing TVs
great TV is great I started like doing
little things like just giving him no
sin and that sort of grew it led to
collaboration where we write scripts
together and so sometimes we work
individually and sometimes we work
together depends on the project so I
started giving like notes but it would
always be like the character stuff you
know what's what's the ranching stuff
and because he's always very good with
the action drive and that kind of thing
although not everybody knows that I do
some of the real kick-ass action yes you
really can't tell reading that reading a
script of ours you really can't tell
whose line is this whose scene is this
it we just kind of trade off depending
and and so ultimately it's both of ours
but it's very funny because there was a
scene between the
our hero and his father who's very
condemning and it's his father's in the
military they're both in the military
and there's this button line where you
know this is very tough line and one of
our friends was in the Air Force really
loved that line and it's this ballsy
macho line and it's a lame they wrote
that line yes so it's great really fun
and but collaboration is terrific when
someone's on your wavelength and so I
really love working with Elaine but but
different since we have feet a couple of
feature projects now where Elaine's the
writer director and we're both producing
so we have two projects in England right
now that we're working on so so it just
depends on on you know what what we're
doing on a given day but also we're very
good both of us are very very good at
multitasking so for instance in a given
week like just a friend for an example
and this is something I learned in TV to
multitask because you're if when you're
on staff you're juggling a lot of balls
and sometimes we'll be working on a
multiple TV show simultaneously which
I've done many times so on a given week
we're working on the on Space Command
one which we're in post on and doing VFX
and editing and all sorts of stuff sound
design
we're on Space Command - editing what we
shot but also getting ready to shoot the
rest of it I'm Elaine just gave me notes
on Space Command three so I'm gonna be
rewriting that script
I'm also finishing the new edition of
The Twilight Zone companion so I'm
writing that and also meeting with my my
publisher on the photographs and all
that and then I might be making notes on
some of the other things I'm writing as
well and Elaine's working on her feature
projects too so and also that's beside
the meetings we're having with like I
had lunch yesterday with a producer
we're scheduling meetings in England it
just continues I mean the one thing
that's fun is it it is a world market
yes and so when you're saying well
there's no place for it here so well how
about friends how about England yes
it's truly a world market and you want
to reach out as broadly as you can
because again one thing that was really
fun about the Kickstarter campaign was
to say oh goody there's geeks all over
the universe you know you know so so you
said they're people like mind in all
cultures and you know across the world
when you're talking about stuff that's
core and so that's one of the real fun
things really fun things about being a
storyteller and running the table
because we get storytellers from all
over the world who are telling core
stories but running
finally fresh and different perspective
and so they come to the table because
Hollywood has the name you know
wonderful stories are being shot and
told all over but Hollywood is the name
and so we have the honor of drawing
people from everywhere and they talk
about their stories and they're
fascinating and so it's it's really a
you know grand fine and we often help
with the immigration issues I mean we'll
hire actors and so forth and that helps
them stay here yeah yeah
the biggest success you feel you've both
had so far and where were you in your
life when this happened would you say oh
well for me the the the biggest success
I've ever had was meeting you know you
know how has the had made everything you
know everything that good has come in my
life has been thanks to that you know so
I that's the high point you know I mean
I've been very very lucky because I met
Elaine when I was I think I just turned
20 and so that was perfection that was
great because again when she met me I
was just a little college dude and there
was no telling if I would accomplish
anything and she had faith in me you
know so I I mean when I met her I
already know she was wonderful but you
know she was taking a big risk in me and
it worked out but but I've been very
lucky because you know think of all the
people who as kids they want to be
writers or directors or or producers
they watch TV shows they say god I'd
like to be part of that world I want to
be on the other side of the glass of the
TV screen and I got to do that I got to
be that I mean my heroes were Rod
Serling and Ray Bradbury because they
were doing TV and books and movies and I
got to do all of that and and so I'm
very very lucky but Elaine had faith in
me and so and I was it's funny because I
was I was gonna say I was unformed you
know when she met me you know I I wasn't
able to do any of the things I can do
now you know I mean and and but she had
already directed off-broadway she'd
already been an actress she had
adventures and so I you know she had
already proved it hurt her
I think for both of us our biggest
success is whatever we're involved in at
the moment we're not most looking back
and we're sort of drunk drunk on the
moment the enthusiasm of the moment and
the way it's kind of sad to say well
that was the big time no I think it's
that it's the it's the ongoing journey
you know you have to sort of the success
is the ongoing journey and you have to
be a little bit crazy you know with each
new thing and say this is going to be
amazing and so I don't think it's like
one thing it's we don't rest on our
laurels I mean right now is the exciting
time I mean to have my own studio to
walk into a building filled with
spaceship sets I mean I mentioned that
when I was 10 I went to the Star Trek
set and when I step onto that stage with
our with our spaceships that's it's the
exact same feeling it's that same thrill
I'm 10 years old again and and to be
able to create something's like every
day is like Christmas it's just
basically my god wonderful actors
wonderful people to work with and to be
able to write and direct and produce
with Elaine is such a thrill because she
brings the meaning she makes sure that
what I'm doing is meaningful is working
and and when we're done with this we'll
go back with our editor and we'll sit
down with our editor and continue
working and that's just thrilling and so
so we're just very lucky to be where we
are in doing what we do so what would
you say to someone that might be
listening to this that feels that maybe
they hit their peak however many years
ago and they feel that there's no
there's no way up for them for whatever
reason yeah oh just say oh I would say
that that has nothing to do with their
craft I think that has to do with
feeling stuck in life and take a walk
around the block talk to people
volunteer that you know bring yourself
back to your work something has happened
there's been a disconnect and then I
doubt very much of it has to do with
their craft it has to do with something
they've lost something inside which can
easily be regained if you don't tell
yourself a story you know it's the
stories that destroy us and to just say
get really enthused about your life and
it's not in the past all those years
even though years of misery there's you
know we were talking to a large group of
writers in seminar
and two riders in the far front corner
this large room they raised their hand
and said well we're from Denmark and
we'd love to work here but we don't
really were very different a different
culture you know we really feel we have
nothing to say we feel like such
outsiders and I said well why don't you
just turn around and look at everybody
else in the audience and they did and I
said okay everybody else in the audience
who here feels like an outsider and
every hand in the room went up and I
said I think you've got something to
write about and what's what's important
a lot of people don't realize that it's
like I feel so alone and to say well
everyone tends to feel secretly very
alone and so you understand that even in
your loneliness you're not alone so have
the courage and share it and that makes
you and everybody else feel less so and
so I think those feelings to say I'm
feeling it but I know it's bogus and I
will push through and what I would also
say in that regard is every day that you
wake up is another beginning and the
past in a way is an illusion it's sort
of like it's gone
you can't reclaim it so all you can do
is say what do I want to do with this
day what do I want to do this moment and
you can be an entirely reborn person but
look for people who are positive look
for people who have a good life energy
look for people who allow you your dream
and if you don't find them where you are
come here come to where here where your
dreams can be made possible and don't be
stopped you know but
don't be stuff ever stopped and find the
way to make it happen in one of my
scripts that I'm in the middle of
polishing it was that there's a place of
second chances you know and and and
somebody says they don't believe that
there's a place where you can get second
chances and he was because if somebody
found out that there's a place of second
chances then this place would be flooded
and the fellow he's talking to he said
laughs and says no no you're thinking of
the town down the way of damn good
excuses yes
and I think that when sometimes people
feel defeated their part of them is
looking for the good excuse and not
really for the second chance because
that we can make endlessly yeah but one
thing I'll say just in conclusion in
that regard I would urge anyone who has
a dream to pursue it and to not be
deterred and to take a take a chance you
know and to really go for it and one day
I came home and there was a message on
my answering machine and it was Ray
Bradbury
and he'd come across something I'd
written and he loved it and he invited
me to his house and that was of course
the thrill of a lifetime and I went to
his house and we hit it off and we
became great friends and the thing that
amazed me about Ray was that I knew him
in his 80s and into his 90s he died at
91 and and through that whole time I met
him after he'd had a stroke and he his
schedule as a writer had been to get up
five days a week
right for three hours then have lunch
take a nap do his business his writing
you know the business of his career in
the afternoon and then evenings and
weekends for his family and he did that
for 70 years and when I knew him he'd
have stroke and his mind was fine but he
couldn't type anymore and he ends
handwriting was even very difficult so
what he would do to continue writing was
he would wake up in the morning holding
the words in his head he would then call
his daughter in Arizona and dictate the
words to her she would type them and
then fax them them to him and he would
make hand corrections on on the
typescript he in that he'd that that was
how he wrote and he was writing two new
books a year through his 80s into his
90s and he was made of iron and so and
so this is the kind of person that I
wanted to be my inspiration in my mentor
because I saw how determined he was
nothing was going to stop him and that
was wonderful to see and certainly
something I want to emulate so I would
urge everyone to take that to heart and
not be deterred